are leave a voice message for Bart
you'll get back to you right after the
beep merge
[Music]
so I thought this would be a little bit
fun to talk about since you know many of
us are in the entertainment oh no more
dead animals like the dead animals you
want to talk about one more dead gorilla
sperm yeah
is that how you think of me Bart
just dead animals I just put your
Chapstick on you [ __ ] psycho all
right so uh anybody here a fan of Taylor
Swift
wait I thought this was Taylor Swift the
entire time you guys told me
I like Taylor that's how we got him here
yeah yeah he makes fun music fun music
she's cool yeah she's cool uh she uh
recently uh we found out that she turned
down a Super Bowl offer what whoa why do
you think she turned on us because it
was a fake 100 Bill wow this is fake
because that's not her demographic maybe
no I wouldn't say that she's got a very
very big demo I mean I I know I know she
has a big demo but I just think like
people might not want to rock to her if
the last time was like Dr Dre and Snoop
and stuff oh it's a hard act to follow
yeah
that's interesting that'll be a really
really interesting like sub reason that
you would never admit to never thought
of that yeah that's okay it's like
imagine you're hosting the Oscars and
then you see Will Smith singing the
front row and you're like uh I'll go
backstage I'm gonna [ __ ] slap me or
something that's true you want like
someone else to follow that because
they're gonna be talking about last
year's and then this one they're like
Taylor Swift it's a big contrast that is
that is a little bit she comes all
[ __ ] Crypt out and she does her
covers her covers of all West Coast
Music that'd be kind of cool
that's a good guy acoustic version
acoustic [ __ ] yeah acoustic [ __ ] album
yeah
so uh the reason that came out was
actually she said that she didn't want
to do it until she had finished
re-recording all of her first six albums
re-recording is that because of that um
that rights issue exactly what happened
back in 2019 yeah back in 2019 Scooter
Braun was part of a group that acquired
the rights to her first six albums and
that basically just pissed off Taylor
Swift because like you know she didn't
have the rights to her own masters why
didn't she acquire them then she was a
little girl it's hard to do
well scooter her producer or or agent
the whole time
I think he was her agents really yeah I
knew this was Bieber's age yeah he's
everybody's agent Bieber and Ariana
Grande
and PSY but yeah Ryan you you just you
just gave that uh you gave that very
affirmative like yeah it's really hard
to do because you're obviously familiar
with the music business I mean that's a
that's something that like anything
rights-wise it's hard to get from a
label labels just don't want to give you
anything like the first the first
scooter get in there and get it I mean
most of the time someone else will have
it yeah but yeah so I mean nowadays
though obviously with technology social
media everybody realizing that they can
do that you know people are rappers were
even doing it with nfts like in the last
like you know two years and stuff like
that everybody's making a much more
independent kind of like uh Avenue for
themselves in order to make sure they
maintain the rights to all their stuff
we've already seen like major Milestones
of this like for example when Apple
acquired the rights to like the Beatles
music and was able to take Beatles music
and put into Apple I remember who had it
before that Michael Jackson yeah yeah so
he would dangle in front of Paul
McCartney like I got it or or what is
remember when it was like a huge deal
when uh Macklemore was rising to fame
and he was like the only independent
independent artist who was doing that at
the time too and there was a lot of that
kind of like Stick it to the Man own
your own [ __ ] then they're not truly
independent most of the time if you're
it has to go on unless you own the label
that you're you know Distributing from
right because even even Interscope has
an independent Branch where like
Independent Artists go under Interscope
independent side still under it yeah but
they're allowed to like you know promote
themselves as like oh I'm not in label
so at the time Taylor uh Swift was
pissed saying that she uh she was sad
and grossed out uh scooter Brawn has
since sold the best out that's a great
quote
totally aggressive has since sold the
master recordings and Taylor vowed to
re-record them to in effect regain
ownership so she like there was this
whole time where she told all of her
fans to stop listening to her music that
was already out under the labels and
support like the re-recordings of music
and she was she had already done I think
uh two of the albums red and fearless
she's already re-recorded and a ton of
work dude damn this is a hard worker do
they know that which ones are the newer
albums because I wouldn't know
well if if you're a fan I think that you
you know that uh she put out six albums
already and then all those sixes because
she hasn't put out a new album of new
songs she's only recently put out two
albums of her old albums re-released and
re-recorded but if they got the same CD
cover picture and everything then you're
right everything's probably got that
like nice legal 15 change and if you're
at amoeba nice and then they both have
the same cover you're like is amoeba
even alive still yeah they are in San
Francisco got it and then you're just
like which CD do I buy
I don't even buy CDs anymore but is it
like um because your your instrument as
a person changes yeah so like you're
you're not even gonna sound this like
Usher at 17 there's not is his voice is
way different than the Usher now but if
it's super different she's all Shake It
Off yeah it's all deep now like I want
to support her but damn like you know
the song uh Tevin Campbell the can we
talk or wow yes I do so that's all like
he recorded when he was like 15 like
even he can't do what he did yeah you
know so it's like how how do you
reproduce the instrument that you're not
anymore Auto auto-tune I wish there was
a voice actor here to talk to you guys
about that yeah anyways uh it was nice
talking to you guys
let's talk about this goldfish with the
big ass
we could take this yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know it's uh there
there has to be
but I think about it when uh they just
re-released or not re-released but
released new episodes of Beavis and
Butthead and Mike Judge is uh uh you
know uh he's still doing the voices and
it still sounds great yeah he's still
killing it I don't know how I can
understand that in the obviously extreme
sense but if they still sound close
enough or the same it's like at that
point youthfulness you know what I mean
puberty is a factor but I mean for girls
it's going to be easier to do right I
don't know I don't know yeah it's not
like she suddenly had like eight octaves
deeper of a voice coming into her
re-release you know what I'm saying and
on top of that too like um imagine
Bieber redoing baby it's like that's
different before it can't happen baby
baby oh he also probably would never
want to do that over
I'm taking my rights back it was so
gross yeah I am so grossed out with it
it's gross so it's gross the voice
acting World
um do people get fired because their
voice changes
sometimes they do sometimes sometimes
that's a it's threatening sometimes uh
there are people that their voice does
change or their their memory of what's
like your beauty oh the memory of it
you're not like uh you sound like James
and then if someone's in charge that
doesn't agree with like oh well he
sounds fine she sounds fine but what
happened to him
there could be moments where another
actor might have to come in yeah
especially in like things like Simpsons
where it's the same people for so many
years well the thing too about that is
like the the character evolves as well
so you have to take that into account is
that yeah Homer didn't Homer sounded way
different it was like more of a Walter
now a Walter Matthau impression uh boy
go to your room and now we know him as
this big dumb idiot right that sounds
like this
even with Bugs Bunny even with bugs he
kind of sounded like just a normal guy
with a New York accent and but now it's
this thing that we're all familiar with
but yeah Homer is probably one of the
best examples of that oh yeah yeah he's
like was that good donut
can you now I know why you brought this
can you can you record uh my voicemail
being later and say you better pay him
100 bucks for cameo
that'll be so cool I'm gonna keep that
forever
leave a voice message for Bart he'll get
back to you right after the beep merge
fill your throat with cheese like that I
don't know
I mean look at me I mean you know that I
have internal cheese yeah
they're gonna harambe me they're gonna
take my cheese kill me and then make it
that's so cool I don't even know how to
follow up with that like where do you go
from that you just [ __ ] dude
do your best Wesley Snipes impression go
Wesley Snipes I don't know like him in
real life or him as a character want him
to get canceled I just want Anthony to
get [ __ ] up
are you able to pick up little voice
traits and just like actual Bart right
now like and sound like him it's tough
you all have particular sounding voices
um you know I would have to like really
study that one study all the voices do
you like just hear things way
differently when you're hearing like
you're like oh I could hear the little
this I gotta put this together it's yeah
I think it's it's a musicality all in
the ear and and kind of just can can I
because like when I was auditioning for
Looney Tunes I didn't know that I could
do Daffy I was always thinking about
trying to perfect oh wow until the The
Voice director is like can you do Daffy
and I was like I don't know can I so I
started watching and and then trying it
you know and just in around friends
Workshop in it yeah yeah just like
seeing if it would get a reaction from
someone and that's usually if it gets a
laugh then you go forward right because
you know you're you're getting somewhere
uh and then eventually it just it
happens I always think of uh Daffy Duck
as Richard Dreyfus with a lisp you know
yeah
what we're dealing with here marathon is
a perfect eating machine and all he
wants to do is eat and make little baby
sharks
crazy basically Richard Dreyfus here
what like with the ability to sound like
anything you want what makes you choose
your default voice yeah
oh I don't know that's a good question
um you can literally just be bugs 24 7
if you felt like it or you could you
know sometimes you just feel like bugs
yeah I mean you know if again it's just
if it's in the situation for here I
would do it if you want if you ask me
like as soon as you get here don't break
character and be bugs I would have done
it in a heartbeat done we would have
been harambe because you're so
comfortable you're so comfortable you
could just do it sure and now I am I
think before maybe not but I think
because I've I've always just thought of
you know ever since Who Framed Roger
Rabbit I I may have thought that those
characters were real yeah oh yeah do you
ever use your talent to like defuse
tense situations
send me to the Ukraine and I will
de-escalate right yeah I can only
imagine just like something real intense
and then it just goes off put those
machine guns down
not war we better listen to that guy
thank you